charlemagne you called um your meaning
divine uh and anita you said it was
magical why did those words and feelings
transpire
absolutely so when i
wrote the book i i had this time it was
during 2020 right when i finished it and
there were so many things going on in
the world and i was like you know what
it's time for this book to come out and
then my best friend yadi
said you know what i'm gonna go to the
ocean and she's like i'm going to ask
yamaya who is the main character of the
book who is also a goddess who is a
black mermaid yes
and she's like i'm going to ask what you
need to do with this book so she went
and she heard you need to give it to
charlemagne
wow
yes and so she did and two days later he
called me and he was like do not sign
with anyone else
i'm putting this book out anita what was
your inspiration for this book okay so
first of all i have to say before i say
the exact inspiration
that growing up
you played such a huge part in my
development i did yes you did and
because as as a magical child that's how
i call myself because i could see things
before they happened i would see spirits
within my family everyone knew when
someone was pregnant and so
when i saw firestarter
i felt like
i was seen
i was heard i'm trying not to cry right
now
because you played such a huge part in
the development of my
magical gifts wow and so i think for a
lot of people because i've had this
conversation with a lot of people and
what is really amazing about that is how
fiction stories can come in and bring
real healing right in reality and so
that's what
shallow waters does
and i've brought in
yamaya who is an orisha she is a euroba
goddess the goddess of the ocean
she is a mermaid she was said to have
watched over our ancestors as they went
over the middle passage
and when i was like okay there was a
black mermaid that watched over my
people as they came over you know they
they
not necessarily like so she would watch
over the ones that either were thrown
over or fell overboard
and also our
our ancestors souls who made it so that
we can be sitting here right now having
this conversation um well we all need
more optimism in our lives so
charlemagne and anita are going to share
some of their secrets to creating
positive energy charlemagne what's your
ultimate tip for bringing good vibes
um be a blessing to other people like i
always feel like you know
regardless of how you're feeling that
day
like regardless of how you're feeling
that day if you do a good deed for
someone like a genuine
good deed just because i think it it
automatically will make you feel better
that's genuinely what what what gets me
off and anita you have a small exercise
that people can do yes i do
are we about
yes we are
so this is an amazing exercise called
the yes breath that i learned from my
tantra coach who her name is is sami
zadora she's now past and is in the
ethers
but um it is an amazing breath that we
can all use if we're ever going to an
interview or something where you want
more energy
it will bring the energy into you and so
everyone if we can all stand up okay do
this all right let's try this i'm in and
what we're going to do is we're going to
place our hands up in the air
and you're going to imagine an intention
right an intention that you want in your
life
imagine that it's right up there on the
ceiling and you could bring it down into
your body by bringing your arms down and
saying yes
right
and we're gonna yell it out loud so that
our ancestors here so that god here so
that all the spirit's here
and ready yes
oh i mean
yes yes yes
yes
yes
[Applause]
keep those hands up feel that energy
that you just made in your body
bring your energy down
ah and say thank you for yourself for
taking this moment
thank you
thank you anita yes
thank you so much for that beautiful
ritual
and make sure you go get shallow waters
by anita cole patch first time i read it
i said to myself i had to let my
daughter read this because it truly is
like a healing you know journey
especially for young for young girls so
please make sure you go get shallow
waters
nice stocking stuffer yes
yes
yes all right
don't forget to don't forget to catch us
the god's honest truth with charlemagne
the god fridays on comedy central 10 9
central um and you can get your copy of
shallow waters on sale right now
[Music]